bonjour à tous xiao me a officialisé un
smartphone pour les gamer un smartphone
qui allait en tout cas d'être plutôt
cool c'est le black jack est ce que ce
black shark va venir concurrencer le
réseau folle on va essayer dans cette
vidéo de regarder un peu les points de
comparaison du point de vue la fiche
technique le réseau fon j'ai eu
effectivement j'ai testé une maître de
conf et il est génial pour du jeu sur le
taux de rafraîchissement un 100 m c'est
vraiment un produit qui est vraiment au
cas plein plein plein de choses qui sont
superbes d'un point de vue technique ce
chien omis bien évidemment je ne vais
pas entre les mains je lui en tout cas
pas encore eu entre les mains ne vous
inquiétez pas ça ne saurait tarder mais
on va regarder du produit de la fiche
technique on va regarder le prix et on
va voir au final 6e black shark et en
quelques ronds sérieux du réseau fon et
on y va
[Musique]
d'un point de vue esthétique c'est quand
même dingue parce que les couleurs
convoi rappelle vraiment des couleurs de
razer on voit effectivement la volonté
de chiens omis de marcher sur les pas de
raideurs pour lui faire une concurrence
directe
est-ce qu'ils vont y arriver oui ou non
ça c'est autre chose mais on va vraiment
en attendant la volonté du fabricant
chinois d'aller se positionner sur ce
marché parle beaucoup des smartphones de
chiots mais schumi arrêté c'est une
offre à 360° il n'y a pas que les
smartphones il ya beaucoup de choses il
ya de la ouache à l'ordinateur
les maîtres du roman gage enfin qu'il ya
énormément de choses c'est une marque
qui développe énormément qui devrait
arriver dans l'hexagone d'ici très peu
de temps donc on va rester connecté là
dessus parce que vous allez voir qu'il y
avait énormément de choses à dire sur
cette marque comme ça intéressant sur ce
produit forme la csac c'est qu'en plus
de ça vous pouvez l'associer avec un
petit gamepad vous le mettez dedans et
ça vous fait une console portative
bien évidemment on peut jouer
directement sur l'écran mais avec un
petit jaune pâle
c'est quand même beaucoup plus sympa
alors je vous ai fait un petit
comparatif avec mon écriture dégueulasse
on va pas se mentir
donc je vais pas vous la faire lire
parce que je sais même pas si vous y
arriverez tellement que c'est hyper mal
et on va regarder un petit peu point de
détail par point de détail du point de
vue de la fiche technique avant de
pouvoir effectivement le prendre en main
et puis de voir un petit peu les
sensations parce que je produise les
pentes aujourd'hui comme je voulais dit
mais du point de vue de la fiche
technique c'est quand même très très
intéressant parce que déjà ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau de l'écran le réseau fon à
un écran 5,7 pouces eee jay z os en 2560
parmi les 4 140 x l 515 ppp avec un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz son
rafraîchissement j'en ai déjà parlé dans
une précédente vidéo où effectivement
j'ai pu tester le réseau fon on se rend
compte sur du gaming sur de la prise en
main sur du jeu que effectivement ça
apporte une fluidité ça apporte quelque
chose qui est vraiment hyper claire et
perd agréable sur de sortir du jeu
notamment
a contrario le chez home in black shark
à un écran 5.99 pousse presque dire si
tous un exemple de chipoter cdu oled
séduit fhd plus avec une résolution de
2560 parmi les 80 pixels au format 18 9e
un taux de rafraîchissement de 60 hertz
ya pas de taux de rafraîchissement de
100 verte
par contre ils ont une puce dédiée qui
s'appelle la puce pixels works qui est
vraiment là pour optimiser l'affichage
alors bien évidemment on a d'un côté un
réseau fon avec ce taux de
rafraîchissement 100 m
une puce dédiée là on parle vraiment le
choix sur le papier ça serait vraiment
intéressant pouvoir le prendre en main
le tester et à ce moment là je peux
vraiment vous dire ce que j'en pense
côté processeur vous avez du côté du
réseau fon instinct dragoon 835 8 coeurs
cadencés à 2,45 et gigahertz et de
l'autre côté du côté du ch et au milieu
du biac chaque vous avez un seau dragon
845 cadencé à 2,8 ghz
sans blague charles vous avez soit 6
soit 8 gigas de ram tandis que sur le
réseau fon vous avez 8 gigas de ram au
niveau de la puce graphique vous avez
sur trésor phone une qualcomm adreno 540
tandis que soit de la carac vous avez
une adreno 630 le stockage sur le black
star de chez home is et du 64 giga ou du
128 giga extensible de son réseau
refrence du 64 giga extensible du point
de vue de l'appareil photo vous avez sur
le mac charmed xiaomi un double capteur
de 12 et de 20 méga pixels avec une
ouverture de f 1.75 tandis que son
trésor phone vous avez double capteur de
12 et 13 mégapixels
pas d'info sur l'ouverture faite de la
vidéos en 4k bien évidemment tous les
côtés côté selphy sur le lac sharks et
une caméra 2 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.2 et sur lazar folle
c'est une caméra selphy de 8 mégapixels
vous pouvez filmer en full hd
de ce point de vue là la batterie c'est
la même chose c'est du quatre millions
paire eur d'un côté comme de l'autre sur
le blackjack vous avez un nom et aux
oreilles 8.0 avec une interface jong-il
tandis que de l'autre côté vous avez un
android cette porte un point au gabon on
imagine très bien que soit votre foi
doit pouvoir a priori à gré des soussous
oreo vous avez de l'usb tixier de tous
les côtés vous avez pour le black shark
une
double carte sim parce que son réseau
fon vous avez une simple carte sim là
vous êtes des smartphones qui pèse près
de 590 grammes d'autres coûté 190
grammes et ce qui est intéressant aussi
sur le black sand chahoumi c'est qu'ils
ont un système de refroidissement
liquide qui vous permettra de connaître
l'opéra tueur de 8 degrés en utilisation
intensive à ce que vous allez avoir des
jeux qui vont consommer énormément donc
ce qui permettra effectivement d'avoir
une meilleure durabilité puis surtout
d'éviter que le cours des choses trop et
tous les risques qui peuvent en découler
côté tarifs c'est toujours la impôts de
bât blesse le réseau fon aussi entre 720
à 750 euros tandis que ce produit là
pourrait être entre 385 à 450 euros donc
un produit beaucoup moins cher alors si
on regarde purement la fiche technique
effectivement un gamin qui arrivait
beaucoup plus tôt c'est réseau fon
chiant me devait au moins se mettre au
niveau voir frapper un peu un peu plus
fort maintenant reste à voir quand même
les finitions reste à voir le produit
une fois dans les mains les heures bon
en tout cas les produits sont
relativement bien fraîche sauf que le
réseau fon est une belle bête c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très très bien
fabriqué reste à voir le premier shiomi
si on y travaille vraiment bien aussi
ils ont vraiment d'excellents produits
je vous dis reste à voir maintenant en
termes de prise en main mais savez quand
on regarde sur le papier l'écran est
légèrement plus grand bon c'est pas non
plus un angle d'un côté ce qui est
intéressant pour esor c'est ce taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz est
vraiment un confort lorsque vous jouez à
des jeux c'est vraiment vraiment très
très agréable le snapdragon 145 sur le
black shark est quand même plus puissant
que lui 135
reste à voir maintenant sur des jeux en
utilisation hyper poussée est ce que ça
va vraiment changer quelque chose
mais ce qui va vraiment faire une
différence dans celle entre ces deux
produits ce qu'il voulait c'est lorsque
vous avez dû pousser dans ses
retranchements voir un moment lequel
aura des limites sur quel jeu vraiment
le comparer avec vraiment des jeux
équivalent on d'un côté comme de l'autre
les pousser à fond les faire chauffer et
faire tourner et ensuite pouvoir compter
pour ça je pense que même celui qui se
raconte le mieux c'est le gamer le gamer
qui a l'habitude de ces jeux qui
al'habitude un petit peu de devoir les
imperfections
donc je sais pas d'ailleurs si vous êtes
un gamer si vous avez testé déjà le
réseau fon est ce que vous en êtes
satisfait oui nos est ce que c'est un
produit que vous avez ce que c'est un
produit vous pourriez avoir moi je
trouve que le premier super cool je me
suis vraiment très très curieux de
tester ce chiot me black shark boire
vraiment stehen enlevante et voir en
utilisation
s'il fait la différence oui ou non donc
en attendant de pouvoir tester je vous
invite
évidemment à me marquer tous vos
commentaires questions suggestions vos
amis qu'on puisse en débattre apporter
des choses constructives
d'un côté tous ceux qui ont utilisé le
réseau fon dites moi ce que vous en
pensez ceux qui ont du chien au mieux le
blackjack de folie personnes cela ne va
essayer ceux qui ont des produits cioni
est ce que vous seriez séduit par ce
produit si vous aimez gaming ont marqué
moi tout seul on discute ensemble comme
d'hab vous invite à vous abonner parce
que ces produits on va les tester on va
les prendre en main on va un petit peu
aller les chercher pour son compte ce
qu'ils valent donc rester connecté bien
évidemment comme d'habitude vous invite
à laisser deux jolies pouces markine à
toutes vos questions suggestions en bas
je vous donne rendez vous très bientôt
pour une nouvelle villiers vidéo
arrivait plus à parler vous avez pas il
ya plein de choses qui arrivent c'est
hyper cool donc restez connectés d'ici
là soyez sages portez vous bien
et bah vous embrasse tous
[Musique]